so I'm house-sitting in South I
shouldn't give away where I'm
house-sitting because obviously so I'm
house-sitting for family oh I'm taking
care of a dog too
I'm house-sitting a house and a dog for
the month of November
it's 10:30 2 a.m. I moved in at 6 a.m.
this morning they went to the airport at
6:30 for their flight to India for a
month husband wife and two kids I
already thought the dog pissed on the
rug but it did it already gave them a
ton of dog treats
I figure you have to impress a dog
within the first couple days of being
with them that establishes a
relationship the neighbors are outside
already with their kids
the neighbors are already outside a lot
a lot so that'll be a fun interaction
the house already smells like a gas leak
first weird thing I found in my room
um Playboy magazines lots of them just
displayed openly on a shelf in the room
two shelves above the Playboy magazines
are two Indian Barbie dolls the Star
Wars sexy alien Edition my room is a
shrine to valuable family heirlooms
oh Jenny McCarthy I mean who keeps
Playboy magazines there's a lot of words
in here actually this man has two kids
whatever it's fine
good to keep
uh excuse me that's pretty much it so
far so far so good I need to check on
the gas